the most successful in the automotive
industry robots operating today in the
hands of real people are ones that are
traveling over 55 miles an hour and in
our constrains environment which is
Tesla vehicles so Tesla autopilot so I
just I would love to hear of your just
thoughts of two things so one I don't
know if you've gotten to see you've
heard about something called Smart
summon with Tesla System part Apollo
system where the car drives zero
occupancy no driver in the parking lot
slowly sort of tries to navigate the
parking lot to find itself to you and
there's some incredible amounts of
videos and just hilarity that happens as
it awkwardly tries to navigate this
environment but it's it's a beautiful
nonverbal communication between machine
and human that I think is a from it's
like it's some of the work that you do
in this kind of interesting human robot
interaction space so what are your
thoughts in general water so I I do have
that feature new driver Tesla I do
mainly because I'm a gadget freak right
so I it's a gadget that happens to have
some wheels and yeah I've seen some of
the videos but what's your experience
like I mean you're your human robot
interaction roboticists you're legit
sort of expert in the field so what does
it feel for a machine to come to you
it's one of these very fascinating
things but also I am hyper hyper alert
right like I'm hyper alert like my butt
my thumb is like okay I'm ready to take
over even when I'm in my car I'm doing
things like automated backing into so
there's like a feature where you can do
this automating backing into our parking
space our bring the car out of your
garage or even you know pseudo autopilot
on the freeway right
I am hyper sensitive I can feel like as
I'm navigating like yeah that's an error
right there like I am very aware of it
but I'm also fascinated by it and it
does get better like it I look and see
it's learning from all of these people
who are cutting it on like every time I
cut it on it's getting better right and
so I think that's what's amazing about
it is that this nice dance of you're
still hyper vigilant so you're still not
trusting it at all yeah and yet you're
using it what on the highway if I were
to like what as a roboticist we'll talk
about trust a little bit what how do you
explain that you still use it is it the
gadget freak part like where you just
enjoy exploring technology or is that
the right actually balance between
robotics and humans is where you use it
but don't trust it and somehow there's
this dance that ultimately is a positive
yeah so I think I'm I just don't
necessarily trust technology but I'm an
early adopter right so when it first
comes out I will use everything but I
will be very very cautious of how I use
it
do you read about or do you explore but
just try it they do like it's crudely to
put a crew they do you read the manual
or do you learn through exploration I'm
an explorer if I have to read the manual
then at you know I do design then it's a
bad user interface it's a failure Elon
Musk is very confident that you kind of
take it from where it is now
to full autonomy so from this human
robot interaction you don't really trust
and then you try and then you catch it
when it fails - it's going to
incremental improve itself into full
it's a full way you don't need to
participate what's your sense of that
trajectory is it feasible so the promise
there is by the end of next year by the
end of 2020 it's the current promise
what's your sense about that journey
that test is on so there's kind of three
three things going on now I think in
terms of will people go like as a user
as a adopter will you trust going to
that point I think so
right
like there are some users and it's
because what happens is when tech
knowledge at the beginning and then the
technology tends to work your
apprehension slowly goes away and as
people we tend to swing to the other
extreme right because like oh I was like
hyper hyper fearful or hyper sensitive
and it was awesome and we just tend to
swing that's just human nature and so
you will have I mean it is a scary
notion because most people are now
extremely untrusting of autobot they use
it but they don't trust it and it's a
scary notion that there's a certain
point where you allow yourself to look
at the smartphone for like 20 seconds
and then there'll be this phase shift
will be like 20 seconds 30 seconds 1
minute 2 minutes position but that's
people right that's human that's humans
I mean I think of even our use of I mean
just everything on the Internet
right like think about how relying we
are on certain apps and certain engines
right 20 years ago people have been like
oh yeah that's stupid like that makes no
sense like of course that's false like
now it's just like oh of course I've
been using it it's been correct all this
time of course aliens I didn't think
they existed but now it says they do
obvious nth earth is flat so okay but
you said three things so wanted okay so
what is the human and I think there will
be a group of individuals that will
swing right I just teenagers gene it I
mean it'll be clean it'll be adults
there's actually an age demographic
that's optimal for a technology adoption
and you can actually find them and
they're actually pretty easy to find
just the based on their habits based on
so someone like me who wouldn't was it
no robot Isis would probably be the
optimal kind of person right early
adopter okay with technology very
comfortable and not hyper sensitive
right I'm just hyper sensitive because I
designed this stuff
so there is a target demographic that
will swing the other one though is you
still have these humans that are on the
road that one is a harder harder thing
to do and as long as we have people that
are on the same streets that's going to
be the big issue and it's just because
you can't possibly know us you can't
possibly map the some of the silliness
of human drivers right like as an
example when you're next to that car
that has that big sticker called student
driver right like you are like oh either
I am going to like go around like we are
we know that that person is just gonna
make mistakes that make no sense
right how do you map that information or
if I'm in a car and I look over and I
see you know two fairly young looking
individuals and there's no student
driver bumper and I see them
chit-chatting to each other I'm like oh
yeah that's an issue right so how do you
get that kind of information and that
experience into basically an autopilot
yeah and there's millions of cases like
that where we take little hints to
establish context I mean you said kind
of beautifully poetic human things but
there's probably subtle things about the
environment about is about it being may
be time for commuters start going home
from work and therefore you can make
some kind of judgment about the group
behavior of pedestrians or even cities
right like if you're in Boston how
people cross the street like lights are
not an issue versus other places where
people will will actually wait for the
crosswalk or somewhere peaceful and but
what I've also seen so just even in
Boston that intersection the
intersection is different so every
intersection has a personality of its
own so that certain neighborhoods of
Boston are different so we kind of end
the based on different timing of day at
night it's
so there's a there's a dynamic to human
behavior that we kind of figure out
ourselves
we're not be able to we're not able to
introspect and figure it out but somehow
we our brain learns it we do and so
you're you're saying is there so that's
the shortcut that's their shortcut
though for everybody is there something
that could be done you think that you
know that's what we humans do it's just
like bird flight right this example they
give for flight do you necessarily need
to build a bird that flies or can you do
an airplane is there shortcut so I think
the the shortcut is and I kind of I talk
about it as a fixed space where so
imagine that there is a neighborhood
that's a new smart city or a new
neighborhood that says you know what we
are going to design this new city based
on supporting self-driving cars and then
doing things knowing that there's
anomalies knowing that people are like
this right and designing it based on
that assumption that like we're gonna
have this that would be an example of a
shortcut so you still have people but
you do very specific things to try to
minimize the noise a little bit as an
example and the people themselves become
accepting of the notion that there's
autonomous cars right right like they
move into so right now you have like a
you will have a self-selection bias
right like individuals will move into
this neighborhood knowing like this is
part of like the real estate pitch right
and so I think that's a way to do a
shortcut when it allows you to deploy it
allows you to collect then data with
these variances and anomalies because
people are still people but it's it's a
safer space and is more of an accepting
space ie when something in that space
might happen because things do because
you already have the self selection like
people would be I think a little more
forgiving than other places and you said
three things that would cover all of
them
the third is legal liability which I
don't really want to touch but it's
still it's it's still
of concern in the mishmash with like
wood policy as well sort of government
all all that that whole that big ball of
mess yeah gotcha so that's so we're out
of time now what do you think from a
robotics perspective you know if you if
you're kind of honest of what cars do
they they kind of kind of threaten each
other's life all the time so cars are
various I mean in order to navigate
intersections there's an assertiveness
there's a risk-taking and if you were to
reduce it to an objective function
there's a probability of murder in that
function meaning you killing another
human being and you're using that first
of all yeah it has to be low enough to
be acceptable to you on an ethical level
as a individual human being but it has
to be high enough for people to respect
you to not sort of take advantage of
completely and jaywalking fronting and
so on
so I mean I don't think there's a right
answer here but what's how do we solve
that how how do we solve that from a
robotics perspective one danger and
human life is at stake
yeah as they say cars don't kill people
people kill people people right so I
think now robotic algorithms would be
killing right so it will be robotics
algorithms that are prone oh it will be
robotic algorithms don't kill people
developers of robotic our that was kill
people right I mean one of the things as
people are still in the loop and at
least in the near and midterm I think
people will still be in the loop at some
point even if it's a developer like
we're not necessarily at the stage where
you know robots are programming
autonomous robots with different
behaviors quite yet not a scary notion
sorry to interrupt that a developer is
has some responsibility in in the death
of a human being this uh I mean I think
that's why the whole aspect of ethics in
our community is so so important right
like because it's true if if you think
about it
you can basically say I'm not going to
work on weaponized AI right like people
can say that's not what I'm gonna do but
yet you are programming algorithms that
might be used in health care algorithms
that might decide whether this person
should get this medication or not and
they don't and they die you okay so that
is your responsibility right and if
you're not conscious and aware that you
do have that power when you're coding
and things like that I think that's
that's that's just not a good thing like
we need to think about this
responsibility as we program robots and
and computing devices much more than we
are
yeah so it's not an option to not think
about ethics I think it's a majority I
would say of computer science sort of
there it's kind of a hot topic now I
think about bias and so on but it's and
we'll talk about it but usually it's
kind of you it's like a very particular
group of people that work on that and
then people who do like robotics or like
well I don't have to think about that
you know there's other smart people
thinking about it it seems that
everybody has to think about it it's not
you can't escape the ethics well there
is bias or just every aspect of ethics
that has to do with human beings
everyone so thing about I'm gonna age
myself but I remember when we didn't
have like testers right and so what did
you do as a developer you had to test
your own code right like you had to go
through all the cases and figure it out
and you know and then they realize that
you know like we probably need to have
testing because we're not getting all
the things and so from there what
happens is like most developers they do
you know a little bit of testing but is
usually like okay - my compiler bug out
and we look at the warnings okay is that
acceptable or not right like that's how
you typically think about as a developer
and you'll just assume that is going to
go to another process and they're gonna
test it out but I think we need to go
back to those early days when you know
you're a developer you're developing
there should be like this say you know
okay let me look at the ethical outcomes
of this because there isn't a second
like testing ethical testers right it's
you we did it back in the early coding
days I think that's where we are with
respect to ethics like this go back to
what was good practices only because we
were just developing the field
yeah and it's uh it's a really heavy
burden I've had to feel it recently in
the last few months but I think it's a
it's a good one to feel like I've gotten
a message more than one from people you
know I've unfortunately gotten some
attention recently and I've got messages
that say that I have blood on my hands
because of working on semi autonomous
vehicles so the idea that you have semi
autonomy means people will become would
lose vigilance and so on that's actually
be humans as we described and because of
that because of this idea that we're
creating automation there'll be people
be hurt because of it and I think that's
a beautiful thing I mean it's you know
as many nights where I wasn't able to
sleep because of this notion you know
you really do think about people that
might die because it's technology of
course you can then start rationalizing
saying well you know what 40,000 people
die in the United States every year and
we're trying to ultimately try to save
well but the reality is your code you've
written might kill somebody and that's
the important burden to carry with you
as you design the code I don't even
think of it as a burden if we train this
concept correctly from the beginning and
I use and not to say that coding is like
being a medical doctor but think about
it medical doctors if they've been in
situations where their patient didn't
survive right do they give up and go
away no every time they come in they
know that there might be a possibility
that this patient might not survive and
so when they approach every decision
like that's in their back of their head
and so why isn't that we aren't teaching
and those are tools though right they're
given some of the tools to address that
so that they don't go crazy but we don't
give those tools so that it does feel
like a burden versus something of I have
a great gift and I can do great
awesome good but with it comes great
responsibility
I mean that's what we teach in terms of
you think about the medical schools
right great gift great responsibility I
think if we just change the messaging a
little great gift being a developer
great responsibility and this is how you
combine those but do you think and this
is really interesting
it's it's outside I actually have no
friends were sort of surgeons or doctors
any what does it feel like to make a
mistake in a surgery and somebody to die
because of that like is that something
you could be taught in medical school
sort of how to be accepting of that risk
so because I do a lot of work with
health care robotics I I have not lost a
patient for example the first one's
always the hardest right but they really
teach the value right so they teach
responsibility but they also teach the
value like you're saving 40,000 but in
order to really feel good about that
when you come to a decision you have to
be able to say at the end I did all that
I could possibly do right versus a well
I just picked the first widget and right
like so every decision is actually
thought through it's not a habit is not
a let me just take the best algorithm
that my friend gave me right it's a is
this it this this the best have I done
my best to do good right and so you're
right and I think burden is the wrong
word if it's a gift but you have to
treat it extremely seriously
correct
you